After seeing Alien: Covenant, you probably
have some questions.
That's okay — like Prometheus before it,
Alien: Covenant was long on terror, and short
on answers.
As such, we're here to do our best to get
to the bottom of some of these mysteries,
and try to figure out just what the takeaway
is from Ridley Scott's latest extraterrestrial
murderfest.
So now, with a very obvious spoiler warning,
let's try to explain the ending of Alien:
Covenant.
Why did David help Daniels and Tennessee?
If you were surprised when the synthetic at
the end of the movie turned out to be the
evil, British David and not the kind, bland
Walter, then you haven't seen a lot of movies,
have you?
The minute you see Michael Fassbender playing
two robots — one good, one evil — you
have to know that the bad one's going to pull
the ol' dipsy-doo-switcheroo on our heroes
by the end of the movie.
It's basically movie law.
However, even if the David reveal was somewhat
predictable, it does raise the question: why
did David help Daniels and Tennessee during
the final showdown with the xenomorph?
It's not completely clear, but it seems likely
that David suffered from a planet-sized case
of hubris.
His whole plan seems to center around finding
ways to make the xenomorph better through
experimentation.
We got a glimpse of some of his trials and
errors when we saw his lab — along with
what remained of Elizabeth Shaw from Prometheus.
It's possible that the final showdown aboard
the Covenant was, for David, a test to see
whether this version of the xenomorph could
get the better of Daniels and Tennessee.
It failed, so he's got plans for bigger, badder
aliens when the ship finally arrives at Origae-6.
On the other hand, maybe he simply saw something
in Daniels that he wanted to preserve — again,
so he could use her in his future experiments.
Who's mommy?
At one point, David says that his alien pals
are "waiting for mother."
There are plenty of ways to interpret this
line.
A pretty obvious reading is that the alien
eggs — and more specifically, the facehuggers
within — need a host to do the bloody and
nasty with.
In essence, anyone who provides an incubation
chamber for a xenomorph is "mother."
But what if there's more to it than that?
Prometheus and Alien: Covenant are prequels
to the original Alien franchise — and that
includes Aliens, which was written and directed
by James Cameron.
In that movie, we learned the source of all
those lovely alien eggs: the Alien Queen.
Since we didn't get to see anything resembling
a xenomorph queen before leaving the Engineers'
planet, it's likely that it hasn't been created
yet.
David can't stay up forever making new eggs,
so the queen's creation has to be on David's
agenda.
And that may spell a pretty bad morning for
our hero Daniels when she wakes up...
What did it all mean?
It may be tough to decipher, but it sure seems
like Ridley Scott was trying to tell us something
with his tale of space colonization gone horribly
awry.
Well, let's think about this.
Daniels and her poor, dead husband Jacob came
aboard the Covenant with hopes of starting
a new life on a new planet — just because
it's an adventure.
Meanwhile, poor, dead Captain Christopher
decided to stop on the Engineers' planet in
response to the weird communication they picked
up, and to see if this new world might be
even better than the one they'd been going
toward already.
And David decided that he should play god
and out-create his creators.
What was the result of all of these decisions?
Chaos, destruction, and death.
More than anything, Alien: Covenant is about
the dangers of unchecked human ambition.
If Daniels and her fella had just stayed on
Earth and rented a nice apartment somewhere,
he probably wouldn't have burnt to a crisp
in a hypersleep pod.
And if Christopher hadn't diverted away from
Origae-6 — well, then we'd have had a movie
about the dangers of micromanaging a group
of drunk spaceship workers.
But there probably would've been far fewer
blood barfs and body bursts.
And if David hadn't decided to go full-on
supervillain?
Well, then he wouldn't have inadvertently
become that which he despised.
What happens next?
Two months before Alien: Covenant's May 2017
release, The Sydney Morning Herald reported
on a set visit with director Ridley Scott.
In that article, Scott revealed that he's
already got the next movie in the prequel
series written and ready to go.
That means that the dangling plot threads
of what'll happen when the Covenant arrives
at Origae-6 will be answered in whatever treatment
Scott's got locked in his desk drawer.
Presumably, we'll see a whole mess of xenomorphs
bursting out of colonists, not to mention
a final showdown with David and Daniels...or
whoever else signs on for a sequel if and
when 20th Century Fox announces it's happening.
What happens when the prequels are over?
Not only has Scott got the sequel to Covenant
ready to go, The Hollywood Reporter said that
Scott's revealed plans to make yet another
movie in his prequel series.
That fourth movie would apparently link up
with the events of the first Alien movie from
1979.
And then, no more Alien movies ever, right?
Well…
The entire reason we're talking about new
Alien movies right now at all is that franchises
tend to go for as long as people can earn
money from them.
Whatever your opinion on the current crop
of Alien flicks, making new movies in a recognizable
series of movies is a sure way to earn cash.
So even though these prequels will have to
lead into the original movie somehow, there
will likely be some effort to keep the brand
alive.
That might mean sequels that pick up after
the events of Alien: Resurrection — or,
God help us, Alien vs. Predator.
It might also mean that we're only a few short
years away from Alien: Reboot.
Don't say it could never happen.
Hollywood rebooted RoboCop, Spider-Man, Evil
Dead, and plenty more.
There's no reason that Alien won't be reborn
soon enough, too.
After all, getting born — and reborn — is
kinda what Aliens do…
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love too!